a meeting that was supposed to finish on
Friday but went on for another two days
we ended up with exhausted delegates
long debates but no consensus on new
targets or global rules intamin thing if
the annoyed bully obviously it's sad
that we were not able to reach a final
agreement we were so close but I thank
you for all the long hours trying to
achieve it we were almost there but as
many of you who are in the room
recognize we have made a concrete step
forward in text which give us hope
veneer more will know a nickel but there
was simmering anger in Madrid some of
the world's biggest polluters claim
they're facing unfair demands opponents
say those countries are blocking more
ambitious targets in the end this
meeting broke down on the back of
fractious Rao's I will appreciate if
you'll let us to adopt this document and
we can take note of your concern and
we're terribly sorry madam chair but we
can't accept this paragraph thank you
very much I'm terribly sorry madam
president we can't find the document so
if you could has asked the Secretariat
to explain one more time where it is we
would be very grateful there has been
progress but not enough to satisfy many
observers including small nations
fearful of the effects of climate change
disappointed
what really disappointed countries have
negotiated tirelessly you know and a lot
of time has been taken to listen in to
people to understand the relative
positions but despite all that we not
being able to resolve the most important
issues this meeting came with an
accompaniment of protesting growing
public frustration in a year's time it
will resume in Glasgow and already
there's expectation on what needs to be
achieved there the people who are
exerting the pressure at the moment of
the indigenous peoples the scientists
the youth strike movement many of whom
are legitimately angry at the failures
that have been exhibited by countries so
far and instead of excluding I think the
UK presidency needs to invite those
people in because only then do we see
the kind of pressure on the big
polluters that needs to be exerted if
you now doubt that damage is being done
to our planet that climate change is a
profound threat the words often come
easily action is much harder to deliver
Adam Parsons Sky News